distant avec riadh sidaoui lé directeur
du centre arabe de recherche et
d'analysé politique et sociale bonjour
riadh sidaoui merci d'être avec nous
drake tu sur rt france alors c'est la
guerre entre les talibans et l'armée
régulière sur place quels sont les
rapports de force je pense les talents
des talibans qui signifie renard a pour
largo les étudiants mais les étudiants
quoi les éditos en islamisant noah vise
particulièrement les talibans depuis
leur fondation ils ont été soutenu
massivement par les services secrets
pakistanais ainsi que la ravissante
aujourd'hui on sait que aussi le qatar
se tient l'étal est bon qu'ils ont un
bureau à temps et c'est le qatar qui a
aidé les négociations entre les
américains et l'état les baux à mon avis
et jouissent de ce que nous appelons
sciences politiques le pouvoir local
ils sont les parce qu'il la société à
gasquet société tribale dont coop
l'entrée balle ils sont puissants très
puissants et ils ont gagné les batailles
avant l'alliance avec certes ils ont
commis une grave erreur avec l'alliance
de sama bel laden al qaïda mais je pense
les américaines ont pardonné parce que
je pense qu'il y a des désaccords se
crée entre l'état les bons all is
américains pourquoi édiles ont
recommencé leurs batailles et en quoi
ils sont déterminés à libérer entre des
gays mais le pianiste ans est dominée
l'organiste ont encore de nouveau je
pense l'appui pakistanais et l'appui
implicite des états unis d'amérique
peut-être aussi afin de afin de contrer
la russie et les ex républiques
soviétiques
en tout cas on apprend aux cobras
goûtant les villes qui tombe dans les
mains des taliban et on sait s'ils
prennent kaboul ça voudrait dire une
prise de pouvoir total en afghanistan
est ce qu'il n'ya encore une chance qui
ne parviennent pas eu ça dépend la
mobilisation des gouvernements
ça dépend le soutien des forces
étrangères au gouvernement par exemple
se tienne le temps est ce que les
américains sont furieux à la fin de se
tenir
le gouvernemental éponge j'ai des formes
doute pourquoi parce que l'examen
qu'elle sont retirés de l'afghanistan je
pense toujours la vieille théorie des
pouvoirs le cas je pense y pense de
cette façon c'est islamistes à les
banques ont été formés par le web
saoudien soutenus par nos alliés
pakistanais ils ont commis une erreur
avec l'alliance de saumade l'aide mais
finalement ils sont pas contre les
intérêts stratégiques américains surtout
si on essaie d'orienter les talibans
contre la russie et les ex républiques
soviétiques comme on a fait pendant la
guerre froide et les années 80 donc je
pense que c'est ça le canton je n'ai
évidemment l'état les bosses enfants
parce que je vis du pouvoir local et
d'une assise tribales alors il ya un
conseil de sécurité des nations unies en
quelle est véritablement la marche de
man avant la loi nous donner ce cycle le
gagner c'est toujours on distingue
contre l'onu le secrétariat et oui le
conseil de sécurité il faut une
résolution du conseil de cercle de ce
conseil de sécurité qui passe par le
chapitre 7 de la charte de l'onu donc
une mobilisation encore des forces
mondiales afin de l'arrêter et lutter
contre les talibans et les forces de
l'otan n'ont pas réussi déjà à
déstabiliser le talent est bon je pense
et américaines sont trouvé des cordes et
des compromis avec le taliban donc cette
fois ci à mon avis il n'y aura pas d
intervention massive de l'étranger parce
que la question d'al qaïda n'existe plus
et laisser ni pratique est-elle encore
possible qu'est ce qui pourrait faire
reculer les talibans finalement je pense
qu'il faut que convaincre karachi
convaincre le pakistan d'arrêter de
soutenir leurs alliés convaincant
peut-être le qatar se dire convaincre
les alliés objectifs des talibans afin
que de talent est bonne quand tu n'es
pas jusqu'à kaboul cc c'est la seule
chance mais je pense que les jeux sont
faits et je pense comme je le répète
toujours il ya eu des accords peut-être
se crée entre les forces de l'otan sur
tout les américains et les talibans
peut-être disent qu'on les laisse faire
finalement s'il travaille pour nos
intérêts ou s'ils ne travaillent pas au
moins contre nos intérêts mais pourquoi
pas encore une fois talibans au pouvoir
à kaboul
oui ça on a fait un tour au bar on dit
que les talibans sont aidés par les
chefs des guerres
que l'armée régulière et td1 par des
milices pro gouvernementales qui sont
tous ces groupes
finalement la société afghane des
sociétés tribales
donc il faut vraiment parfois des autres
colloques afin de comprendre qu'est ce
qui se passe en afghanistan avec la
société tribale on peut pas vaincre et
distribue parce qu'il est à la
mobilisation
le tribun s'ils payent toujours une
question des logiques c'est pas une
question des partis politiques
les américains toujours raison dessinent
un tableau des élections un parlement et
un gouvernement moderne et art mais ce
gouvernement mais finalement le
gouvernement ne tient pas rappelons le
aussi l'ont aidé et former les
militaires vietnamiens du sud mais
finalement société devant l'offensive du
nord c'est presque aussi le même le même
scénario
aujourd'hui le thème les talibans les
étudiants les étudiants doc savage les
talibans et jouissent de cette jouissent
de ce pouvoir local jouissent de ce
soutien massif tribale est pachtoune qui
se tiennent à taller bon et aussi le
pakistan les services secrets
pakistanais jusqu'à nos jours et se
tient les talibans et les mises en jeu
en afghanistan sont très très énorme
pour à karachi et aujourd'hui même pour
les cathares et avant c'était la vie
saoudite
rien de cela oui merci pour votre
analyse vous rappelle que vous êtes
directeur du centre arabe l'on recherche
et d'analysé politique et social mersier
fo